we're now in the first weekend of
november two thousand sixteen so it's
time for me to produce another update
video for my subscribers and viewers and
everybody out there who's interested in
what i'm doing and what my company
reason i owe is doing as well i'll talk
about what went on in the incredibly
busy month of october and what we've got
coming up in the thankfully plus busy
month of november i always like to begin
by highlighting three big things so big
thing number one we produced an
epictetus online class that's that's
open to the public for free specifically
on epictetus is enchiridion i'll talk
more about that in the October section
but you can see the link to it below if
you're interested big thing number two
that's just the first class to come out
later this month you can expect to see
my world views and values class some of
you may have seen some of the videos
from from that when I used to teach it
for a college I have put it into our
reason I Oh teachable Academy and it'll
be available very inexpensively compared
to what people paid for cast that the
whole conversation but we've got other
classes coming out as well so you want
to pay attention to you know what's
what's available and you know what we'll
announce it as they come out I'll
probably produce videos for it or
something along those lines third big
thing this isn't really about this month
or even next month although we can
certainly have the conversations this
month but it's more about 2017 we're
already getting enquiries and we've
already got some dates on the calendar
for talks that are booked and so if
you're interested in bringing me in as a
speaker to do a workshop to do a lecture
to facilitate a discussion contact me
and we'll get the ball rolling and start
talking about it you can email me at
Greg at reason I oh and I'm always happy
to talk with people who are interested
in philosophy or even in some of the
other side things that I
like the you know science fiction
fantasy stuff or the metal music stuff
but primarily philosophy related things
so if you're interested in that like I
said email me and we'll start talking
about it so what went on in October like
I mentioned this was incredibly busy
month probably in terms of speaking
engagements one of the busier months
that I've had although i think i've had
a few that were equally busy in the past
we started things off with a talk here
in milwaukee right over at Marquette
University as part of the Midwest
seminar an ancient and medieval
philosophy the talk was on prior ases in
epictetus is moral theory a more
technical talk one that's really you
know sort of history of ideas you can
see the video for it below the the
Marquette people did a wonderful job in
putting together video footage of it so
I didn't have to do that this time
around that was quite nice of them but
it was really a fun talk and if you're
interested at all in the notion of the
will or choice you want to watch that
then we totally shifted gears and you
know that I do this monthly worlds of
speculative fiction philosophical theme
series at the brookfield public library
so this month it was one of my very
favorite authors philip k dick and the
video for that you can you can see that
as well some great discussion i really
enjoyed putting that one together and
then shortly after that I flew out to
New York for stoic on the historical
gathering the largest gathering of
stoics ever in history took place in New
York City this last month I was one of
the invited speakers I gave a workshop
presentation on stoicism and anger
called struggling with anger stoic
perspectives and practices again videos
is linked to below in the description if
you want to watch it and it was a great
conference I got to meet some of the
people who I've been coerced
bonding with some of them were the other
speakers some of them were you know
other people who I've engaged with you
know in social media or who would
emailed me or taking classes online with
me before so it was really a wonderful
occasion got a lot out of it and then I
came here back to Milwaukee and gave the
same presentation again as a stoic week
event I participated in international
stoic week and you know gave that that
workshop to interested people here in
the Milwaukee area that went quite well
as well so a lot of stoic stuff already
up to that point then we had our online
half hour hagel sessions you know I do
these q and A's as part of my you might
call it outreach online with the
half-hour hagel project and then two
more talks both of them out at Rockford
university towards the end of the month
one was on the basics of stoic ethics
that one's not yet edited and uploaded
yet but it will be soon and another one
sponsored by the the Institute for
ethics and entrepreneurship that one was
called stoicism leadership and
entrepreneurship it included some
reflections on how stoicism might be
interesting to entrepreneurs which which
it is currently so that was all of the
speaking engagements in addition to that
I had quite a bit of writing that I got
done including getting a lot of stuff in
Iraq cysteine oh IDK i was very happy
about that a little bit less in half
hour hagel I wanted to get more done for
that but didn't quite bring it all
together and a lot of work in writing
for stoicism today is we may know I'm
the editor of Stoicism today and part of
the stoicism today project so leading up
to stoic week there's a lot and stoic
and there's a lot of the background
stuff but I also wrote some some pieces
as well and I was working as well on one
of my book projects in particular you
know I've always got a few book projects
going this one was
on stoicism and anger and I'm hoping to
bring it out early in 2017 I also
engaged in some coaching some
philosophical counseling some tutoring
here and there in between and that was
you know quite a bit of work as well and
some cool stuff got started that's
moving into November what else so I
mentioned the epictetus class if you
haven't signed up for it in our
teachable academy and you've got an
interest in deepening your understanding
of Epictetus 'as enchiridion which is
short classic work it's probably the
most commonly read stoicism text i would
say most commonly assigned i created an
online class with 21 videos going
through the enchiridion line by line
sort of like the half hour Hagel series
except applied to this text and not only
did I does include that it's got all
these handouts and worksheets and
quizzes and background material and
curated links a lot a lot of really
great stuff so there's already I think
something like 230 people taking the
class online and it's a free class and
you know so a lot of people really
enjoying it so there's that I also did
some some tinkering around with my
courses on another class plot a course
management platform it just curious I'll
put the link to that below as well and
did get some videos shot and released I
got my six half hour Hagel videos for
the month done that's you know pretty
good given how much was going on I
didn't get to shooting the personal
videos that I wanted to but i did also
release the aristotle videos now we're
working our way through we started
working our way through the end of book
6 and the beginning and into book seven
of the Nicomachean ethics so that's a
lot of stuff that that month as you can
see I was quite busy what do we have
coming up in the
of November so fortunately not as much
travel all of my traveling that I needed
to do i think is done for the the month
and maybe even for the year although you
never know if something's going to pop
up we already had one of our events you
know unfortunately because it was
scheduled so early in the month and I
didn't get around to shooting this video
until later it's already past and that
was on the first I gave a talk in the
philosophers in the midst of history
series at the frank Weinberg library on
Hannah Arendt totalitarianism and the
Holocaust I rentas somebody who haven't
done it a lot of video work on but I'm
actually a really big fan of hers and
that went really well some great
questions from the audience will be
uploading that video probably hopefully
later this weekend so you can watch it
and i'll include the link to it once
we've actually got it uploaded on the
10th at seven p.m. at the brookfield
public library again the worlds of
speculative fiction series which is open
to the public anybody can come we're
going to be talking about mervyn peake
score man gasps trilogy peak was a
fantasy author and illustrator is
actually a very talented artist who
didn't write an awful lot by comparison
to some of the other figures that we've
looked at but the stuff that he's
written is quite literally gorgeous I've
never read somebody whose work was so
who's writing was so painterly as as
peaks is and I really just love the
story that he's telling through that so
we're going to do that on the 10th on
the 16th an online event the half-hour
hagel session you know Q&A if you've got
any hagel related questions or you want
to chat with other people who are
interested in in hegel great german
philosopher that is on the 16th from 5
to 6 p.m. central time so remember that
you're in other time zones one other
thing that's not an event that I am
responsible for but something I get to
go to that's really cool is I'm going to
be one of the attendees or participants
at a con sheehan dinner party they have
this really cool program here in the
Milwaukee area sponsored by some of the
local restaurants the Marquette I think
it's the poli sci dept zeidler
foundation in Wisconsin Humanities
Council and it's a lottery you put your
name in and you might get selected now
I've actually done work in the past on
the work and that this is coming out of
Kant's anthropology from a pragmatic
point of view so I'm really excited to
see how this this plays out I'm also
doing quite a bit of writing over the
month of November hopefully get a lot of
writing done in our exes do IDK my main
blog and in half hour Hagel in stoicism
today we're actually publishing quite a
few of the presentations from stoic on
which is really cool and so I do the
editing on that and soliciting that
we're getting a lot of new posts coming
in but i'll be writing as well in in
stoicism today and i'm hoping to get
some guest post work done for several
other blogs i won't really bring it up
at this point because i don't want to
make promises that i don't end up
keeping but there's some other places i
want me to know do some writing for them
that I'm hoping to actually get done I'm
working a lot on the stoicism and anger
book because I want to have that
finished and ready to get get published
hopefully in early 2017 is a great
resource doing some other academic
writing as well some of it on anger some
of it on other topics someone Gabrielle
Marcel someone dietrich von hildenbrand
Simon Aristotle some you know there's a
lot of different things going on in
addition to that I'm also doing a lot of
course design were
were you know like I said bringing out
some other classes in the reason I owe
Academy and the idea is to you know take
some of the the material that I've been
teaching now for years and put it into
this online formats what people can
study at their own pace on their own
time with somebody who they trust as an
authority on these figures and topics so
the first class that I'm concentrating
on right now is that world views and
values class that I developed as an
online class and then taught for for a
college for a number of years I got to
keep the intellectual property from that
so that's quite good because I'm taking
it and providing what students were
peeing something like anywhere from
1,800 to 2004 I'm providing at a much
much much lower rate you'll be I'll do a
video about it so we'll talk about it
then I'm also going to be opening up
some other classes as well mostly stuff
in in ancient philosophy at first taking
the core concept videos that I've done
as the you know the lecture material but
adding in a lot of cool handouts
worksheets quizzes discussion forums you
know lesson pages all sorts of really
great resources to help students learn
their way through this stuff so if you
like the kind of work that I do in my
videos you're going to want to check out
these courses because they're going to
be pretty great got some coaching some
tutoring some philosophical counseling
stuff already lined up I've got some
pretty cool projects that I'm working on
with clients in these respects people
you know are now coming to me and saying
hey can you can you help me work on this
I need I need somebody who's got a good
good philosophy background to help me
out with this problem this issue some of
it is so some of it is you know working
on particular personal problems and
issues some of it is actually working on
materials that are going to help other
people with it because other you know
psychotherapist sand and other you know
people along those lines are seeking me
out so I'm really happy about that
that's a lot of fun and it's it's really
quite rewarding if you're interested in
my tutorial services or philosophical
counseling / coaching link is below
that's that's all through reason I oh so
if you're interested in that sort of
thing just get in contact with me and
we'll see if we can schedule something
over the the next month or so video work
this is this is a going to be a big
month for getting a lot of video work
done i'm hoping to get quite a bit of
work done on the half-hour hagel video
series I'm really excited with the
section that we're in now we we just for
those who are patreon supporters they've
already seen these videos we've just
finished up with the dialectic of
pleasure and necessity i'll be releasing
those over this month for the general
public patron supporters get to see them
a bit ahead of time anywhere from a week
to a month before i ear them and we're
moving into this other really cool stuff
you know these dialectics like virtue in
the way of the world but before that the
law of necessity and the frenzy of
self-conceit all this stuff having to do
with practical philosophy which we don't
usually associate hagel with but it's a
some of the most fun material in the
phenomenology so we've got that going on
I'm still releasing Aristotle videos
from the these core concept videos I
produced for the Aristotle course last
summer you can see how many videos they
produce that I'm still releasing them
hopefully we'll get we'll get through
all the book 7 and get through most of
book 8 and into book 9 for that and I am
definitely going to be producing some
personal videos this month I've blocked
out some time for it people have been
asking me you know can you do more of
these so I've already got a few topics
in mind that I'm you know mulling over
and I'm going to hopefully shoot at
least one of them this weekend and then
release it later this this week other
than that like I said the third big
thing
is we're you know starting our planning
as we have to do you know when you have
a business for speaking engagements
workshops all those sorts of you know
on-site personal engagements for 2017 so
if you're interested in having me come
and speak to your organization your club
your group whatever it happens to be
reach out to me at Greg at reason I oh
and we'll see what we can do to make it
happen I love engaging with with people
about philosophy you can those of those
of you who know me know that I'm very
into spreading the word you might say
into into opening up access to people
worldwide so I'm happy to talk with
anybody who's interested in booking me
or inviting me or bringing me in that's
it for this update video I hope you have
a great month of November those of you
who are in countries that have
Thanksgiving have a great thanksgiving
if there's other holidays coming up that
i'm leaving out hope you have a great
holiday some others art and keep
plugging away at the philosophy stuff